[Music]
my name's steve duveza
i'm from the university of manchester
i'm a political theorist working in the
politics department
my research covers two main areas
one is the intersection between ethical
conduct
and political efficiency or the
interface between politics and ethics if
you like
and the other areas on a secular account
of evil
the question of can you define and
understand the notion of evil
which isn't tied to some kind of
religious concept or religious
metaphysics
and so you've worked on the problem of
dirty hands in
politics could you set out where you
stand on this
so in in the literature
the problem of dirty hands is a problem
that
goes back quite a way but it was revived
in the early 70s by a man called michael
walser who wrote a
fantastic article called political
action the problem of dirty hands
and since then there's been this
resurgence of research that's been
on the problem of dating hands problem
do you have is effectively the question
of
what is it possible for you to do wrong
in order to do right can you
act in a way that is immoral for the
right kinds of reasons
right in other words can you can you be
justifiably
act in ways that are immoral
and many people think that's impossible
i think it's a
a contradiction it's it's not only a
contradiction it's problematic
because it leads you down a slippery
slope of immorality
but there's a huge number of examples of
uh in real life and film and literature
which suggests that our moral reality is
much
more messy than polit than moral
theories would allow us to have
and what dirty hands tries to do is to
to open up a gray space where
you can in certain circumstances cases
of moral conflicts
cases of moral dilemmas where you can
find a place where
you had to act in a way that broke a
very cherished moral value
to bring about some kind of lesser evil
or to bring about
some kind of noble end and so would you
be able to
give an example of either from the film
or from
real life which shows that it's not as
simple as moral theory maybe okay so
um let's do something really
contemporary
which will be game of thrones so game of
thrones is a typical tv show but
one of its premises is that what do good
people do
one of the premises asks the question
what do good people do in the face of
evil
and without giving any spoilers away
about what's happening in game of
thrones
uh there are certain characters there
that are good uh trying to do good but
they face
very evil opponents which forces them to
do things which are bad
and as a result the consequences of that
means something happens to them for
acting badly
when they didn't want to do that and the
repercussions of not acting badly when
they had to for dirty hands reasons
means lots more people suffer than
otherwise would have suffered
so that's a kind of example what's going
on uh in real life there
you know there are examples but another
very famous one
is that the ticking bomb scenario which
is often quoted in dirty hand scenarios
where
a person has planted a bomb in a major
city say london
uh they're boasting it's going to kill
hundreds of people maybe thousands
you've caught the person they won't tell
you where the whereabouts of the bomb
are you can't get the people out
you know all that kind of things and
it's going to go off in the next 24
hours
what do you do well if you're a
politician the prime minister trying to
protect people in the country
or in that city you're going to have to
try and prevent that bomb from going off
because hundreds will die persons won't
tell you what where the bomb is so
would you be able to torture them now we
know torture is wrong no civilized state
engages in torture
it's a horrible moral crime on the other
hand you're in a situation where if you
don't do it many hundreds of people
might die
so many people think that's a classic
example of how dirty hands arises
a politician who's a good person is
trying desperately
not to do anything wrong is forced to
commit torture
to try and bring about a situation where
hundreds of people don't get killed
now it's very complicated it's not quite
like that because of course you could
end up torturing and still not finding
the bomb and then you've done a terrible
thing without any good results but
nevertheless
that's the kind of structure of the
problem a moral dilemma or moral
conflict which you have to act
to bring about a lesser evil and in
doing that you've committed some kind of
moral violation
and so in that situation is the say the
decision to torture
is that an immoral decision or a moral
decision
yes that's that that that's what
distinguishes it from
other kinds of moral theories dirty
hands is
is unique in the sense that it says you
did wrong and right at the same time
you were wrong to torture but you were
right to try and stop those people from
getting killed
and so you're morally guilty of a crime
and you've got moral pollution but at
the same time
a reasonable person in your position
would have done the same thing so the
question is
should we punish them if so how the
question is
you know is this something that
morally pollutes them forever uh do we
want our politicians to be like that
um do you want politicians not to be
like that michael also talks about
politicians as being
the kind of politicians we need are
those who are good but not too good
what does he mean by that he means
they're good enough so they don't become
corrupt and nasty and vicious and all
the rest of it
on the other hand they'll do those kinds
of things to protect us when it's
absolutely necessary if they do that
and why do you stand on this so i'm i'm
very much a dirty hands theorist that's
that's where i
work in the area and my my work the book
that i'm writing at the moment is all
about
trying to find a philosophical space
where
you can say how that theory operates
uh in relation to its rivals such as
consequentialism or deontology and so on
so and then and then looks at the
various consequences of having dirty
hands
what kind of emotions did you feel
whether you should punish them or not
how does it apply in a democratic
society does it apply in cases of war um
yeah
and so on are there red lines that can't
be crossed yes
and again that's that's part of the
theory that's part of putting out the
criteria for what it is about daily
heads
i mean some some of these criteria are
similar to just war theory criteria
things like proportionality things about
ensuring that
there's a reasonable chance that you
would actually bring about the lesser
consequence
those kinds of things but that's all
part of the intricate part of a worked
out theory of dirty hands
i'm talking about um the sort of leaders
that we want
uh whether we want leaders that are good
but not too good for instance
if we're accepting that uh politics is
dirty in this way
all politicians have to be does that
change what it is to be a citizen
in accepting this well two points two
two things to say to that the first is
that it's not just politicians that get
dirty hands we all can get dirty hands
um it's true that in politics it's more
vivid and it's more common
because the nature of politics where
you're dealing with power and you're
dealing with
the allocation of resources and you have
to protect people you've got special
roles
so that's true in politics we find dirty
hand scenarios much more commonly than
in
everyday life but anybody can face a
moral conflict or dilemma
in any situation where you have to make
choices between
bad and worse and in so doing your means
of
of bringing about the lesser evil or
morally problematic
so that's the first point the second
point about
citizens well it i just recently wrote a
paper
uh which was about democratic dirty
hands
do we as democrats get dirty hands if
our politicians get dirty hands on our
behalf
because remember politicians get dirty
hands to protect us they act in our name
they're doing it to ensure that we are
the people that benefit from their
actions
even if it costs them moral purity or it
puts their souls in jeopardy to make it
rather graphic right
not quite as graphic as that all the
time um
do we not share some of that moral dirt
if politicians get dirty hands on our
behalf that's a very complicated story
about how complicit we are and what our
politicians do
but certainly as democrats if we believe
that we
give the power to our politicians to act
on our behalf if they're getting dirty
hands
there is some kind of roll back onto us
but very complicated story to be told
right and does
agency play a part there and how much
people feel like they are part of the
decisions being made
absolutely so if if you happen to be a
north korean
whatever the north korean dictator does
has very little relevance to your
complicity in this because
you had no say in his being there or
doing what you but for us
because we have the agency of electing
our leaders
some of what they do falls back on us if
we elect rogues
and nasty people and they act on our
behalf well we're partly responsible not
entirely but partly responsible
so yes agency is is is an important part
of this and we
bear in mind that we elect politicians
certainly in this country
who are our representatives they're not
our delegates so there is a
uh obligation for them to use their own
reason and judgment and morality to act
on our behalf
i mean delegates would just do what we
tell them to do they're not delegates in
that sense right
and given that there is a gap between
what they do and our responsibility for
what they do because they can choose in
terms of their own
uh consciousness and so on but
nevertheless we put them there and we
gave them the power
and so some of it rolls back onto us how
much exactly
very complicated story so moving on to
your work
on evil where has that taken you
wherever you focused your research on
right so so my interest in evil arose in
part because of my interest in dirty
hands because one of the scenarios of
dirty hands is
how do you deal with people who are evil
or
evil actions of others so i thought to
myself well what do we mean by evil it
seems to be a term that
many people have disregarded as being
based in some religious
background or metaphysics that's been
completely discredited
so what could we possibly mean by evil
and um
there are certainly certain kinds of
actions we don't think are just very
wrong we think there's something
qualitatively different about those acts
and
we call them evil so i ended up working
in an area
on secular accounts of evil and i my
first paper that i wrote on this was all
about
uh thinking about evil from a dirty
hands perspective uh and i just got into
the the
the discussion with other people who are
working in this area which are quite a
large number
just finished a edited book on on on uh
routledge uh rutledge handbook on the
philosophy of evil
and um there you have all these people
coming in with different definitions of
secular different problems that arise in
the secular country evil and so on
and that was one of the panels that i
did was to talk about
evil at this
little lighting festival do you see evil
as something separate that's out there
or it's something
within humans that's sort of well i i i
don't i don't really think of evil
in terms of looking for an essence um uh
that tends to be a kind of legacy from
the
the religious uh views you know it's
somehow
either something inside us or it's a
demon i i
my particular work looks at what what do
we mean by evil actions
uh now it's true that you can have evil
persons who don't commit evil actions
and you can have evil actions committed
by people who are not evil they just do
an evil thing
and so my focus has been largely on the
evil actions
some of my colleagues been working on
evil persons i'm very much more
reluctant to go that way because i
i think the evil person genuine evil
persons are very rare
and i'm not entirely sure whether even
if they are evil they're responsible for
what they're doing
because many evil persons are you know
seem to be psychopathic in some sense so
question is whether they actually have
agency to to understand what they're
doing that's wrong so
my work is focused mostly on on on the
problem of evil action
but that said i i have tried to develop
a concept of evil
which i think is different from the
different conceptions of evil
conceptions are the different ways in
which you understand the concept
so you can have a concept of justice
which is treat people fairly
but you have different conceptions about
how you treat people fairly you can have
a conservative one a liberal one and so
on
so same thing with evil you can have a
concept of evil about what evil is in
some sense
and the different ways in which you
think that that plays out
and i think the concept of evil arises
because
we live in a society where we rely on
interactions with other human beings for
our well-being
all of us we can't live the lives we
live unless we have this kind of
multiple complex interaction and that is
held together in part by morality in
part by law in part by force
and evil is when
the morality of those interactions gets
subverted
or inverted people who are evil seek to
destroy
if you like the moral landscape in which
we live
they try to obliterate it or to invert
it or to
to warp it in some sense and
i think we all understand what evil is
in the sense that
it's those people who are going to do
things which are going to make any kind
of tolerable life
we have impossible because if you are
starved or tortured or murdered
or left homeless or et cetera you know
all those kind of things
whatever your view of the good life is
whatever it is you're not going to be
able to live that good life because of
those things being done to you by virtue
of the fact of the kind of being you are
a being that needs to be fed and watered
and loved and housed and all the rest of
it
so evil is when persons act in a way to
to
undermine those very fundamental things
that you cannot lead
a good life and that means the
conceptions are different because some
people see that in religious terms some
people see it in secular terms
some people see it in terms of the
consequence of reaction some people see
it in terms of their
motivations and some will see the
combination of all those kind of things
but essentially the concept is all
underlying that is the worry about
the fact that you're going to be
impacted in a way that means you can't
live your life
in any decent or reasonable way because
of somebody else's actions
or or views or whatever and then so how
does an act
come to be named evil then if there's
all these different definitions
so it's a very complicated story so some
people will argue
um in fact most evil theorists will say
it's got to do with the kind of harms
you cause
so catastrophic harms or life-changing
harms or
or something of that acts that cause
that
are evil acts some people will say and
i'm one of those
will say it also can be the kind of
intentions you have
the kinds of motives you have certain
kind of cruelty a certain kind of
humiliation of others those also can
contribute to what it is to be evil
and some people i'm also one of those
that think that is actually a
combination of the two that bring about
one evil actors
so you don't require any kind of
metaphysical notion you can look at it
in terms of
person's motives and intentions and the
consequences of their act to see which
kind of acts are qualitatively different
from mere wrongdoing another acts
throughout history that might have been
named evil that you
oh how long have you got uh
look evil acts go on all the time right
and uh you know
we see it reach a crescendo when you
have a nazi ideology in the background
or when you see
stalin's you know uh marxism or when you
see
mao in operation or the kaimurugi or the
massacres in
in rwanda or what went on in bosnia
i could go on i mean we could be here
for another week and i can
most of our history is filled with cases
of of evil actions towards other people
uh in fact in the late you know we we
are actually a lot better off
now than we probably were hundreds and
thousands of years ago i mean
the routine cruelty that used to take
place thousands of years or even
hundreds of years ago
would absolutely astound us today the
way people were treated
so we're making some kind of progress
but we still i mean that's
that's a whole issue that about where we
are memorials are
but but evil acts are bound they're all
over the place
and of course there's hana iran has
talked about evil that's banal
you can have the banality of evil where
people commit evil acts even though
they're not doing anything that looks
evil
you know you're working in an office
where you break out lists for people
being transported to gas chambers
she called that the manatee of evil
heinrich was organizing the removal of
jews to
concentration camps he wasn't actually
killing them himself but he was making
it possible for millions to die
banality of evil he actually even
thought he wasn't doing something evil
before
or that's his claim anyway i don't think
that's true but that's what he claimed
so that's the banality of you all so
evil evils is
very common evil acts whether they're
genuinely evil persons that's a whole
different
discussion to be had again because there
you're talking about something about
a personality a predisposition to act
that way a certain kind of gloating
uh pleasure from the suffering of others
i'm sure there are people like that
but it's much harder to know whether
these people are psychopathic or whether
they actually are in their right minds
or
what you know so i i tend to shy away
from that kind of discussion
but is there a way we can truly name
such acts as evil if
if we recognize that there's all these
different definitions of evil
well it's it's um it's it's like saying
that something is wrong and recognizing
the different moral theories
right so we all think that murder is
wrong but why we think it's wrong will
depend on the different moral theory
that you use so
if you are a consequentialist you think
it's wrong because of the consequences
of killing somebody
if you are a down tolerance it's wrong
because you've broken the categorical
imperative
if you're a virtue as a system so it
goes on right so we're not disputing
about the fact that there's wrong
actions we're disputing the
why we think they're wrong and the same
goes with with evil i mean most people
wouldn't dispute that
torture and and rape and genocide our
evil acts
they just have different reasons to
think why wired
and where would you like this research
to take you next oh
i'm going to stop doing evil soon i
think it's a very depressing topic to me
too
yeah is this a personal impact of having
to study well i mean
you read you read terrible things about
human beings all the time so
i don't know where it's going to go i
mean i have one i have a i have a
my own particular theory of of evil
which
has been called by others not by me a
disjunctive pluralist theory of evil
and i well it's it's it's a account of
what evil actions are
but it's disjunctive because they're
three criteria and it's pluralist
because it doesn't have one catch or
idea of what an evil act is and i think
that i can
probably get a short book out of that
explaining what it is and
how it interacts with other views and so
i might might have that as a future
project once i finished my
book on dirty hands i might depends i
might just be too exhausted and just
give up all together
is there any examples of sort of
political act that's been
seen as uh dirty but you would say
is actually a case where it could have
been a politician doing a morally right
decision yeah um i mean one
one of the classics of a dirty hands act
is of a man called
stafford crips who was the chancellor of
the exchequer in 1950 i think was
50 48 to 50. and he stood up in front of
parliament and he
said that he lied to parliament saying
that
you there was no plans to take the pound
off the gold standard
because there was economic problems he
was going to remove the pound from the
gold standard to let it
float and he still haven't found
parliament and lied and he lied because
he knew that if he didn't lie
um speculators would then
start selling the pound or whatever the
case may be and destroy the economic
policy he was involved he couldn't even
stand up and say
look i'm not prepared to answer this
question because that would have been
taken as an acknowledgment that this was
going to happen
so you had to stand up there and say i'm
an honest person
because he was considered to be a bright
mindless person
trust me on this not in the works
but of course he knew perfectly well it
was in the works and many people think
at his role as chancellor protecting the
economy
making sure that spec speculators didn't
you know
gain from the british economy unfairly
and so on he had to lie to parliament
now lying to parliament is a problem in
a democracy because you can't
you can't do that and hope to have a
system that's transparent and
people to be able to question you and
understand your policies inside
nevertheless most people think he did
the right thing there
even though he lied right and that's a
case of lying
for the right kinds of reasons now the
question of course is what do you think
of crips i mean
should he now be understood to be a liar
and pay some price for that or should
you just say well that's the job
you did nothing wrong and that's the
fight with dirty hands that's that's the
issue
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv